Cool.
We are back.
I am going to do a whole ton of
streaming this week.
Had a few days working on some other
stuff. got some cool results actually.
But uh yeah, we're going to just be
working on all sorts of things.
Oops, one second.
All right, let me switch the screen
over.
Hey, Jess,
get rid of X. We don't need this garbage
anymore.
Uhoh. Are we using our right microphone?
Yeah, we better be, right?
Yeah. Cool. We got the good mic.
Close all this crap.
And welcome Carlos chess and selfplay.
Amazing results.
Ooh,
cool. I'm looking forward to this. Yeah,
and working with Spencer will be really
good for you as well, Jess. So, um, on
the M side, Spencer is
probably about as good as I am at this
point on the M side at least. There's
still some research stuff. Um, he's
going to he's still learning, but like
Spencer is very very good.
You'll be able to learn to a lot a lot
if you're doing work with them.
Cool. So, the plan for today is uh
mining group.
Let me go grab the refill for this.
Oh, and Cal invite as well. Let me
double check. I got all these messages
from like the last several days that I
just haven't been um
why
something's wrong with my stupid
browser. It's not letting me make a new
window
docket. I will show you. It's mining for
some reason. Um
let's close all this.
Oh, there it is.
I just have to make sure nobody's stuck
random crap on my calendar
and we're going to start on a mini
group.
Well, yeah, this meeting is Friday.
Good. All right. So, this is Minrow.
doesn't depend on anything.
Takes a sequence.
See if we can just adapt this in the
puffer real quick.
Hello Peru
dim expansion factor.
Okay, so this takes returns next.
Return
next prev hidden.
Wait,
let me see the sample code for this.
There's something a little weird with
it.
Take a look at Oh, were you the one who
sent me like the really cool threading
stuff? I'm sorry. I've had just like a
million things. I do mean to get to
this. This is just when somebody sends
me like a big PR like this.
Okay, this is not big in terms of lines,
but like
let me see. I'll at least let me read
through this now on stream at least. Set
back multi-threading
CPU deep but not GPU wide.
Oh, too many threads.
Wait, when you say too many threads, why
Srand is not thread safe.
Yeah,
let me see roughly what this is.
I am going to use this Peru. Like we are
going to have native multi-threading at
some point here and I'm definitely going
to use your thing.
Me see how big this is.
Okay, so C thread step. Like I literally
I haven't even done threading in C.
Well, I haven't done thread based stuff
like ever honestly because you never do
it in Python because Python's threading
doesn't work. So all my like distributed
stuff has been multipprocess based. But
I actually have to go read up on like
all the gotchas for thread safety.
A lot of complexity. Yo, Peru, you want
to do me a favor? if you want to get
this into um into like a real project
where people will appreciate your work a
ton if this helps. Um can you see if it
works on drive if you already have like
your branch set up? If it works on
puffer drive and give speed up there
like you'll get those folks really
excited.
That's an M where there's a lot of like
it's one of the slower M's and it's one
of the ones that's being very widely
used
the NYU Lab and a couple companies.
Yeah, go check on that and I will set
aside some time to like actually get
into this. I mean, you can tell here
it's going to take me like this is not
something I can just like play around
with a little bit and merge like right
away, right? Like I'm actually going to
have to go do quite a bit of looking
into
this and such.
Good projects for job software. Don't
ask me for job stuff, man. I'm This is
not the place to go to for like standard
traditional job path.
Pop in your radar. Libs.
Yeah. So, lib torch. I have the lib
torch trainer working now. Peru. Let me
go see if I missed like anything major.
I'll show you what my DMs look like so
you can see what a freaking mess it is.
20k account.
Hey, this is my freaking DMs. Like, it's
mostly just spam.
torch pin. Okay. Yeah. So, pin is good.
If So, if you can get pin speed ups out
of pin, that actually would be huge.
Pin plus NB is placed lower.
Not that helpful. Pin plus NB. What's
NB?
The thing is I don't know if you can
have pin shared memory, right? Like I
think if you have thread based stuff
then you can do I think you can have
pinned me that is available across
threads. I don't know.
You also have to like not have locks on
it, right? because like you're writing
to the same memory but you're writing to
different locations and you can
guarantee that you're never going to
have race conditions on it. It's kind of
fiddly.
Yeah, the Cthread stuff is exciting
though because we are moving more stuff
lower level um over time.
It's tricky because it's like I'm kind
of walking this tight rope of this stuff
has to be accessible but like at the
same time literally the Python versions
of a lot of these things are more
complex than the C counterparts and it's
not even like they're only more
accessible in the sense that oh Python
that's familiar
but like if you're actually willing to
do this thing the way it's supposed to
be done it's actually simpler a lot of
the way we're doing things.
All right, let me do some mining grew
today though. You look at that.
So mining here.
It's only a little bit faster right now,
Carlos. There's a lot more stuff to be
done here. So, essentially, if I can get
mining to work, then I can also get
BF-16 to work because the
LSTM has like a specific CUDN kernel
that is uh doesn't have good BF-16.
But then this I should just be able to
do whatever with
just going to like copy paste this and
fix it for now.
and
the C++ is easier to read. Oh, okay. So,
there there's not feature parody yet
though, Carlos, cuz the Ford pass and
that it's basically like all the fancy
optimizations that we have for async are
not there on the C++ at the moment. it.
I would expect that they're going to end
up being about the same complexity is
what I will say. Unless we figure out
that we can just do everything on GPU,
but I kind of doubt that.
I need to actually do some more research
on this. Like I need to learn more
systems, man. I need to learn more
systems. I'm not a systems background
like dev, right? My background is AI and
research. I just keep doing more and
more systemsy stuff over time.
Hey, welcome Yaxine. How's it going? Yo,
you've been asking a lot of stuff lately
that um is literally on the docket for
right now, actually. Like the whole
precision thing and Perf and LSTM. Like
this is all what I'm doing this week.
Oh, also you asked about lib torch. Um
here I'll show you.
Yasine
with a Yasine. All right, that's how we
pronounce it. Where did that come from
anyways?
That's funny.
Uh, where is it? Where is it? Where is
it? Why did I just open X automatically?
I should have opened puffer. Here,
I'll show you where the uh the lib torch
is.
It's obviously work in progress,
but we've got
we've got the whole policy set up in lib
torch.
We've got what's this? Forward train.
Got our kneeling. We've got
the evaluate function here.
And we've got step. This is in testing.
And then we've got train. And it's
tested numerically to match. So this
matches exactly with the uh the Python
version as well.
There's still some stuff that I need to
do with this. Um but what I do next with
this is depending on the mining grew
stuff, which is right now me trying to
optimize the LSTM cell and make it be uh
FP uh BF16 compatible.
better doing C.
The C is really easy.
Yeah, the C is really easy. I I wrote a
kernel for um
uh a collaborators over the weekend and
like their entire training is now 3x
faster.
And like I was fighting with like ah do
I do it in Triton? Do I do it in
Cutless? Y. It just ended up being
vanilla just CUDA and way simpler.
Though the the Cuda rabbit hole is a
little deeper than that unfortunately.
Where's going to take it? Glad you're
going.
Yeah, man. Like leave this stuff to me.
You're not going to have a fun time with
this.
Like I believe like the end stuff you
can absolutely get to work but stuff
with like for instance here some of the
logic right now is so the LSTM has uh a
like private probably not open source
KDNN kernel uh that doesn't play nice
with BF-16.
It also is not good for parallelism. You
can get around that with really big mini
batches. It's a limitation but not a
huge one. I want stuff to work for all
mini batch sizes though and I also don't
want to have this separate for evaluate
like cell and sequence model. So
switching to something else would
accomplish that. There are a few
candidates probably Mingru is like the
most likely one. Uh any variant of
transformer is probably going to be
slower. Mamba maybe uh Mingru is
probably the best one of these. But now
what I have to do is I implement it
first in Python. I see whether I can get
it to do uh the same training result on
a few different M's as our default LSTMs
once I parameter match and sweep
everything. And then if that's the case,
right, then I run a more full set of
experiments on more of our M's. I see if
we can like get same perf on neural MMO.
And if I can do all that, then it's
going to be worth putting into the C
version, right? And then from there,
like I could actually get a kernel
optimized for this thing and make it
even faster. Like there are many many
layers to this [ __ ] But then like I'm
also at the same time balancing this in
my head with like the likelihood that
this thing turns out to actually be any
good based on my understanding of how
often I know that even widely cited
published research just turns out to be
bad. Right?
That's a little peak behind the curtain
for you.
Yeah. So, that's what I do, right?
That's what I do on core puffer.
Um, and then you just get to use it
pretty much.
And obviously attackable, right? all the
stuff I make is going to be super
hackable. But like the stuff that's kind
of gated behind these really larger
research questions is kind of better to
just let me figure it out.
Like you can do it. It's just going to
take a ton of time.
Like there's specific tasks I farm out
to people in the community sometimes
because I only have so much energy, but
typically time efficiency wise, I'm
going to be much quicker on a lot of
these things.
Only thing I patched in my vendor puffer
li is how things get moved and I don't
need CPU buffer and is on GPU. Yeah,
things get a lot easier when the end is
on GPU. We actually do have a GPU end
prototypes now as well. And I'm actually
I I think that there might be a way to
make it so I can run the exact same code
like compile the same code for CUDA and
for um C. So, we might be doing that.
That's like a 50/50 toss up whether I
end up doing that for 40 or not. There
are a few other things I want to build
in as well.
Total end will only go faster total if I
parallelize more. Yeah. So, that's the
rough thing with uh with GPUms. A lot of
the time you just need tons and tons of
cores, which is annoying.
Oh, yeah. If you want to do the CPU
implementation, you can try peruse CP uh
CPU multi-threading.
um that actually might be good for you
though. Typically, I don't think you're
running fast enough for that to be the
bottleneck yet, right? Typically, we
only see bottlenecks uh there when we're
at millions of steps per second per GPU.
Like, every time you optimize 10x, you
have to redo everything. It's a pain.
Pocos,
what is that?
I mean, interesting, but I kind of don't
want anything
unless this is like really good. I kind
of don't want anything more between me
and the hardware, right?
Like if possible, I kind of want my
stack to just be like I will be very
happy if I can have my stack just be
less and less Python over time and then
just C and CUDA.
That's all I want.
Yeah. Don't ever ask an LLM to write you
a colonel. It'll just like, oh, you
can't ever just write CUDA. That's
insane. You have to write Triton in Hulk
and you know, or like output a cutless
kernel or output what the [ __ ] What
other things does it have? Oh, yeah. pi
coup x or whatever. It gives you a
million like intermediates.
We'll just like write the [ __ ]
kernel.
It gives you this impression that things
are way more complicated than they are.
So the only thing that's actually
legitimately complicated that I'd really
like to know how to do here is Kublast
isn't open source. So like I can't go
copy paste Nvidia's linear kernel or
maple and then mess with it. Like it's
actually really obnoxious when you want
to do stuff that requires modifying core
operations cuz they're not open source.
I haven't found a good way around that
yet.
Am I working on right now Mingru?
We're going to see if this alternative
um recurrent cell is any Good.
coding boot camp. That's how I landed
here. Well, you'd be surprised. So, the
cool thing with this um this setup here
is there's state-of-the-art RL research,
but there's also stuff that's pretty
accessible to hobbyists and relatively
new programmers.
Um like if you check all these demos on
the website like
many of these are written by
contributors. Some of whom came in
without much experience. Like a
relatively new programmer can totally
write something like this. And uh you
get some exposure to RL. You get some
exposure to science and research. It's a
fun way to learn stuff
and contribute to science. Nope. I am
absolute crap at leap code.
Leak code is a good way to get a job and
a bad way to do just about anything
else.
As a result, I've never bothered with
it.
You already have a job.
Uh, I've never done Okay, I guess I
technically had to pass a few very easy
screens for stupid internships, but like
I've never done a job in which I've had
to go through like that type of
interview, right?
like OpenAI used to not do that even
with the internships then. I had like a
couple internships that they did a few
things, but like I've never just I've
never done that type of a thing. I do
produce a lot of really cool projects
that have some sophisticated engineering
behind them though.
Thankful for you making RL more
accessible.
It's going to end up being, I think, the
uh the biggest hobby area of AI because
it's you can just do indie game dev.
Like, you can do low-level game
programming and then also train bots to
play your game or to be enemies or
whatever. So, I think actually RL is
going to have like RL is going to be the
accessible area of AI, which is kind of
ironic because RL is infrastructure-
wise by far the hardest and it's not
even close.
code hard for square.
Yeah, I don't think I can do most of the
easiest. Like honestly,
it's just doesn't matter. It just does
not matter at all.
Daniel Suarez, hello Suarez. What do you
recommend for new programmers?
Uh, I have a guide for that as well. My
two my two probably best pieces of
educational content. They're on my
articles tab.
There's my RL guide and there's my
programming and ML guide.
So, there you go. Has my best advice in
one place.
wrote practice very gameable. Yes, it's
gameable.
Quick at writing SQL queries
and it isn't basic life check.
Yeah.
And the only the really the only way to
tell if somebody's good is to review
substantial portions of their code
and then ask them about stuff.
Before
LLMs, you couldn't fake that. Now you
can kind of fake it. You can't fake it
just by like asking the LM to write
stuff for you. That'll still be a
disaster. Um, you at least have to be
kind of smart to fake stuff.
But like,
you can't fake actually being effective
at building impressive stuff.
Yeah, the open AI interviews were the
best I think the best done I'd ever had,
which were you would just go give a
research talk open to the whole company,
have to answer questions, and then you'd
chat with like three or four other
engineers for an hour a piece
about research and about, you know,
projects that you've worked on stuff.
They're working on like where stuff
might fit.
Yeah, objective but uninformative is not
helpful
and like ultimately it is a very biased
process. Like for instance, there are
people who write code in a way that's
complete completely anathema to me um
who have built good stuff, right? But
like I could never work with them. They
would make it impossible for me to get
anything done just by virtue of the way
they structure all their stuff.
So you're there is actually an element
of compatibility to it.
RL not for puffer tried with SP3 is such
a joke. Yeah. [laughter]
Well, this is what I'm trying to do
partially, right?
I mean, it was kind of like a happy
accident if I'm going to be honest with
you that Puffer ended up making
everything this accessible. But like
once I saw it working, I was like,
"Okay, awesome." You know, if I can
advance cutting edge research and make
this a super accessible area where there
going to be tons of people working on
cool little projects, that's great.
What are you doing right now? I am
currently testing or integrating mining
the puffer. And uh the goal is to see if
we can get this thing to match
performance
uh when you parameter match it with an
LSTM. And if I can do that across a
bunch of ends, then uh this thing is
going to be a huge huge speed up for
puffer. So
little bit of integration, bunch of
experiments,
and the goal is pure speed out of this
thing. I do not need this to be
asymtoically better whatsoever. I just
need it to be faster.
Okay, cool.
Somebody has a colonel for this.
Yeah, Lucid Reigns has all the
implementations. How's your time at
OpenAI? Best place I've worked by a
mile.
Very different place from what it is
now, mind you.
But back then it was awesome.
Uh Andre was not there. I
I've never worked with him personally.
Uh I've chatted with him a bunch when he
was a PhD student when I was interning
and at Stamford. Uh Ilia, yes, I also I
didn't work with him directly, but you
know, I had lots of conversations with
him. He's pretty awesome as well.
I really have nothing bad to say about
Ilia. Great guy,
visionary.
Um, really, really unique way of
communicating research, very effective
guy.
Mhm.
Gman as well.
I'd like to think I had some pretty
insightful
uh additions while I was there as well.
At least some of the things I told them
turned out to be true a few years later.
I go back. Not as it is today.
They're not doing any of this stuff
anymore, man. to do language models.
Yeah, but it's okay. I don't like um
Yes. I don't need um I really don't need
a ton of research uh resources to make
this work. Like RL will just be set
within a year or two. If I just keep
doing what I'm doing now, RL will be
well well taken care of.
That's kind of the awesome thing about
this, right?
Um, probably the biggest one, Jess, was
I told them that the emergent tool use
transfer experiments, which were
originally one of the main, like one of
the main purposes of that project. I
told them that those really weren't
going to work very well at all and that
you're not going to get transfer by
training on one task and then getting uh
and then like fine-tuning on other like
sort of highle related tasks. You're
only going to get transfer via like wide
distributions of domain randomization or
task conditional or something like that
which is then what XLAN did much more
effectively several years later. So, I
pretty much told them exactly how and
why um one of their larger projects was
not going to work. And it happened in
the exact way that I told them.
So,
I don't I guess it's not a contribution
if they don't freaking listen, but not
much I can do about that.
How much did it cost?
I don't know who got him anyways.
Um,
that that's somebody who I've like lost
all respect for though based on me
attempting to work with like various
bits of his papers.
Like
the whole narrative set by the dreamer
line is just false.
which is unfortunate because if the
dreamer like if the dreamer papers
actually worked the way that it's
written on paper
um or like they work in the way that
it's pres they're presented it would be
probably my favorite line of work and
I'd be completely changing the way I was
doing a lot of my own stuff, but they
just don't.
It's inefficient capital intensive.
What? What is not interested in language
models? Not really. Spirit, there are
plenty of people to go do language
modeling now. There's nobody to do RL.
I'm going to do what I I'm going to do
the thing that only I can do.
I'll link him to repro every day. Wait,
what?
Wait, why pre-training took so interest
inherently capital intensive?
Yeah, that makes sense.
you build off previous iterations
or you got to start what my stuff so my
stuff you can technically build off
previous iterations but it's so fast
that we don't bother right if I can
train a new model from scratch in 30
seconds.
Yeah, Car Pathy is right. Like the way
RL's being used on language models right
now is really dumb.
Doesn't apply to the stuff I'm doing,
though.
Like look, technically if you wait
around long enough, right? like the
language models will like there will
eventually be a time where you can just
run like big language models on a chip
like one chip at home very cheap and
like that will change the calculus a
bunch but like I'm not waiting two
decades for that to happen or even one
decade right like I'm going to have RL
working well before then and even when
like the chips do get that powerful that
just means that we're going to be able
to to run like exabyt of simulations on
one chip.
That actually would be a fun project.
Try to run um first RL experiment to use
an exabyte of simulated data. I don't
think it's been done before.
I think we're still an order a couple
orders of magnitudes off of it being
reasonable though
Oh well, he has open source code, dude.
It's just really bad and it's really
brittle
and like most of the things in the paper
you can just run ablations on them and
they don't hold up.
So like there's a huge difference
between you got the results that you
wrote in the paper and the thing works
in the way that you describe it, right?
It's presented as this like super robust
general thing and it's just like really
shitty and brittle and uh it's actually
very difficult to even like it's very
difficult to replicate this stuff as
well.
the tiny RNet like the tiny recursive
nets paper like that sounds interesting
but I haven't really seen anything about
it yet you know like I haven't actually
gone and looked
uh why is this hidden shape this like
why is this like this
I'm not going to go read the paper right
now on stream, man. I'm working on this.
I saw it on Twitter.
Yeah. So that's what we're doing now. Um
this So if this actually works, this
will actually make Puffer even simpler
because we won't have to do like we
won't have to do this really obnoxious
cell plus like sequence model split
thing. It'll just be one kernel.
form Twitter approach to not
illegitimate citations. Oh, you think
legitimate citations mean anything?
I hate to break it to you, they're
equally meaningless
at like some constant ratio.
Yeah,
you would not believe how unbelievably
[ __ ] like acade academia it is. Is
like if you just kind of model the world
as like uh everything being middle
school playground dynamics
and you just like assume everything is
stupid until proven otherwise, you're
going to be more right. you're gonna be
right more of the time than if you
assume that the serious people must
actually actually like must actually
know what they're doing.
Both parents are academics. Yeah, I did
not have that benefit. I had to figure
this [ __ ] out on my own.
Wait, why is it doing this? To hidden
and gatechunk.
Yeah, that is also true.
That is also true.
is not all bad.
Real models
predict next observations.
like train a model that predicts the
next observations and then you can do
stuff like have the model hallucinate
the future and train on it.
The problem is training a predictive
model is kind of hard and kind of slow.
It's one of those things that just
sounds unbelievably cool until you start
thinking about it and then it's still
unbelievably cool. That's just like no
nowhere near as practical.
Can they be auto reggressive? Uh yeah,
you do train you train the world model
auto like you do train the world model
that way though you don't usually train
it on sequences the same. No, you do
pretty much train it the same way as a
language model. Um but then you also
have RL in the loop.
I don't know. I wrote a blog post. It's
like why is it the why RL failed to
bootstrap? It mentions a couple things
about That
open world game age. What limitations?
I wouldn't say that we're running into
like what's preventing us from running
this stuff on that. Well, it's two
things, right? Um,
we don't have enough ends that are like
that that we can use for research that
are also fast. Like my own neural MMO
and a few other adjacent works are
probably the only ones. Uh, there's some
core algorithm challenges still, but
then
I guess it depends on like the horizons,
right? Like could I make could I make
like enemy AI and stuff or like little
like localized things that would run in
an open world? Yeah, absolutely.
It's also just demand, right? Like
um if you know if uh a big game company
were to come to me tomorrow and say hey
we really want this to work. We want to
like support the research around this
and then we want to have you know
exclusive uh inter like we want to have
exclusive access to information on like
how to get these into our game and stuff
like I could do that but right now there
is not the like usually industry doesn't
have that sort of demand until the
research is relatively close and that's
still like the type of thing that's
probably going to be puffer five
ego ruins academics X
guilty is charged there. Got an ego that
can fill the room. But
the thing is crazy is you actually kind
of have to have a massive ego because
otherwise it's like you're fighting the
entire
you're kind of fighting the entirety of
human ignorance and research.
You kind of have to be a little nutty to
assume that you're going to be able to
figure something out that nobody else
has.
Multi policy league selfplay something
on the road map test policy. Yeah. So
Julian people are working on selfplay
right now. Uh multi-policy league base
though that is another story because
that's like the only source of that is
Alphaar and I am not personally
convinced that that is even a good
implementation
uh of that type of work. So, we're
starting with more the Dota style
fictitious selfplay and then we're going
to see from there
because like it's it's unclear whether
league play is good. It is absolutely
clear that it is woefully inefficient.
So,
why wouldn't you fork a Runescape and
runic simulation?
So, uh Huk that is very close to my PhD.
Uh, and what I would have to do is I
would have to do that and then go line
by line in that code, port it to C and
make it run a thousand times faster. And
that would be like in terms of things
that I would be super excited about,
like that's at the top top of the list.
Um, because that would be the best
benchmark for RL period. Um, there are a
bunch of other things that you can also
do that are hard and more practical, but
like that would be an amazing amazing
thing. And we have like a mini MMO on
the website, which is neural MMO 3,
which gets a decent bit of the way
there, but it doesn't have like, you
know, quests and a lot of structure to
the map and, you know, area based
progression and that sort of a thing.
What if you got help for doing that? It
would have to be very qualified help
because it would be a big project and
you can't make a mess of it. But then,
yeah, that would be awesome.
I mean, I wouldn't be surprised if we
could get it would be bigger than any of
the environments in Puffer right now.
That's for sure.
It's mostly just the huge amount of
content, right?
Super crazy good hop in. So if you're
interested in this and serious then what
you would want to do first. So take a
look at my work here. This is neural MMO
3.
So this guy I'm playing it now, but it
was the bot playing it before. You can
run around.
There's a market. You can buy stuff.
You can sell stuff. You can fight
enemies. If I can find one that's not
super overleveled. This one is probably
going to kick my ass. Yeah, that one's
going to kick my ass.
Uh I don't think you can kill a level
five from level one.
Yeah. And I get one shot almost.
Kind of hard game, but you can level up.
And if I just hit, you know, take my
hands off, hit control, now the agent is
playing it. And these guys actually will
get like level eight or 10 most of the
time. And they will equip armor, they'll
buy stuff, they'll trade with each
other. Um, so there's a lot of
complexity in here already, but
obviously a full MMO is way bigger than
this. If you check the code for this
one of the first the environments that I
wrote
pretty much the whole code is just this
file like 2.8k 8k lines. A good like
third of it is the rendering, maybe
more. The rendering is kind of hard, but
the rest of it's very simple. C. Uh, the
goal would be to keep probably this or
higher code quality. So, probably even
simpler like more like simpler, more
straightforward than this. And then
there also a couple research questions
to answer on the representation of the
game that we'd want to figure out as
well for the next version. Oh, this is
not solved yet, by the way. Like,
probably a good thing to do would be to
solve this environment fully first. This
is only a third of the way solved. Like,
it only gets to level, I think, eight or
10 out of 25.
Thousands of people willing to. You
never get thousands of people willing to
who are capable. There aren't thousands
of like really really good programmers
just available to do stuff
where you cannot admit you were wrong.
Oh, so if you give me something where
I'm like clearly unambiguously wrong, I
will be the first to admit it. But the
standard is just very high. The most
recent of these was was Muon, right? I
thought Optimizer research was a waste
of time and then Muan so did everything
in our on our project. So there you go.
But if you give me something where it's
like you're maybe right, but I still
think that I am, and you don't have
proof, then I will fight you
on Everything.
You actually have to be very very
stubborn in research. Like being
open-minded is actually not a great
trait a lot of the time in research cuz
like you kind of just have to get like
you get strong evidence for your
approach. You're never going to be
certain. People are going to get strong
evidence for their approaches. They're
not going to be certain. And then you
just have to ignore those people and
like keep digging at your thing until
you know one way or the other and not
get distracted.
All right. What the hell happened with
this?
What's missing from Neural MMO 3? Well,
it's not a full MMO, right? It's
basically it's like a procedural
generated map with biomes that don't
really do much. There's an elemental
system that doesn't really do much.
There a couple weapons and there's some
armor and levels, but like the maps
don't really have structure. Um, it's
kind of unclear, right? like how you
would do a procedurally generated map
that doesn't have um or with like big
chunks of structure like good PCG like
that's actually pretty hard or if you
wanted to do a fixed map like Runescape
is then that's a lot of hand work and
then also like it's kind of annoying to
do no PCG in RL. Um you just create all
sorts of really screwy training dynamics
that are not exactly the problem that
you care about studying.
Um,
let's see.
Uh, there's no like location based
progress, right? Like starting all the
agents from one spot and then having
them progress is kind of hard because
like the agents just crowd each other
out at the start. Like that type of
thing is pretty difficult. There are a
lot a lot of challenges with getting
this to a full full scale.
somewhere I can read your thesis. You
can. It's very long and boring
cuz like a thesis is really just a whole
bunch of papers stapled together.
So, what you can do is if you really
want to, you can look here and you can
get my thesis, which is some ungodly
number. Yeah. 170 pages. But if you want
to just spend an hour and learn quite a
bit,
um,
it's on YouTube. It's an hour. People
enjoyed it a decent amount.
And
just Google this.
I am new here. Is this an environment
optimization
li or does pufferlib also provide
algorithms? Um so pufferlib has fast ms
fast vectorzation novel and very good
hyperparameter optimization and one
algorithm. It's not a reference library
of a bunch of like existing algorithms.
It's our current best algorithm which at
this point is uh PO with uh some pretty
substantial improvements that have been
widely tested.
You can train a lot of our baseline
environments in like 30 seconds on one
GPU.
I'm trying to figure out how you're
supposed to call this thing.
Oh, the hidden dim is just wrong. That's
fine, right?
Thanks. We'll give it a try. Yep,
there's the whole Discord. Like ton of
people in there if you get stuck. I also
stream a ton, so you can always ask on
here. It's usually quite simple to get
started though.
Hey, Kvert.
Oh,
why hello there.
That is interesting,
don't you think?
Okay, cool. This thing has some legs.
We're not going to at least spend all
day screwing with it to no effect.
Uh, the model is too small. It needs to
be parameter matched. There are a couple
other things. I am exhausted. I got to
get myself a cup of coffee and do a
couple sets or something like holy.
Oh yeah. Why do I have my camera like
this as well? Hang on.
Let's get my full
There we go.
Much better.
join you for that couple sets.
All right, let me see.
Um,
we'll do something hard.
We do some app training. Let's try
dragon flags instead of eight of those.
And then coffee.
That is the hardest ab exercise I know.
If anybody knows a better one,
be my guest. But I think Bruce Lee knew
what he was doing.
Chief,
what does that mean?
Look,
look at the pictures of the things I'm
posting. [laughter]
That's funny.
Okay, this is almost perfectly parameter
matched with my original.
Okay.
Uh, do I need to like totally re sweep
the hypers now's
mess with the learning rate a little
bit.
H.
So, what do we do with this? We just
launch a sweep. I guess that would be
the smart thing to do, right?
Let me see what this is supposed to be.
So it's
So this is your linear
lur
sigmoid.
I guess we just sweep this version
first.
Oh, and this has the fast sweep stuff on
it, doesn't it?
Yeah, this does. Perfect. I should just
be able to like
Uh, this not training is sketchy cuz
this just trained on my other machine.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, that's fine.
and this guy can live over here for a
bit.
Did I say that you would be given a
description?
Oh, you're stupid.
I suppose then we should test the
stacked form next.
Yeah, they're reporting their three
layers stacked.
I see table two. I don't see table
three.
Endex.
Oh, there it is. I am dumb.
But it does come out. Table three comes
after uh before table two in the text.
So kind of silly.
Okay. So they have this thing
where they say this thing does a pretty
good.
And I want to see if this is their three
layer variant.
So, apparently this thing is more meant
to be stacked.
Let's go take a look at our um our sweep
so far and then we will attempt a
stacked version of this.
Kind of funny. I never really tried to
do a stacked
version.
Okay,
so 450 is best so far.
Well, I can figure it out pretty easily
now.
I guess I never tried two-layer LSTM
actually.
That's kind of dumb in retrospect,
right?
Okay, let's just do
let's do a simple two layer for now.
Oh, and then you do do we want to split
it here or not?
We probably don't want to split here,
right?
What made you want to try Mingru?
Um, the fact that we're doing like
smaller batch size stuff with
constellation
and that LSTM also doesn't have a Bflat
16 kernel. So, this can potentially kill
two birds with one stones. Also, I have
not uh chatted with you since. Congrats,
Finn. Well, I guess that's a little
pretentious to say. I think I should
just say welcome. Uh
yeah, we have some fun stuff to work on
soon.
Well, not that soon, but still.
We have one layer mining sweeping right
now. Not doing amazing yet.
Oh, careful sit fin. It's still a It's
still a contractor arrangement.
But yeah, we're super excited. This is
going to be a lot of fun.
Yeah, Finn just did like such good work
that I couldn't possibly say no.
I think the drone PR is still probably
the cleanest like the cleanest
non-trivial code I've received.
super fast, worked super well, kept
working on it, you know, have like
several little projects now spinning out
of this.
It's either already or shortly will be
on the drone.
code is basically based on it. See,
there you go.
Help my boy Finn out here and uh give
one of his drone things a repost once in
a while, eh? [laughter]
He's doing really cool work.
undergrad writes better code than uh
basically any of the MIT PhDs I know.
And the math for that stuff is a total
pain in the ass as well.
Pixel only drone. PhDs write papers, not
code. Yeah, that's why science is such a
mess because the experiments still
require code and if you're bad at
writing the code, then the experiments
end up being wrong half the time.
That is a solid little renderer that you
have there.
If I wanted like a really really dumb
hack, I'd add one extra channel with
edge detection on this just to see, but
you probably don't need it. This is
awesome.
Yeah, the 64x 64 is like surprisingly
more than enough.
32 by 32 might be a little rough, but
honestly, you could maybe even get away
with it.
Works with four. It works with four
pixels. What? Are you serious? Wait, it
works with four pixels. 4x4 pixels, 16
pixels.
That seems sketchy.
All right, that seems sketchy. Do they
have any other obs or something?
You told me 16 by 16 or 8 by 8 like
maybe. But that's ridiculous.
All right. But if it works with four,
like that should be able to run millions
of steps per second. No.
It would still be hard for us to do
pixels everything, right? Even if we
could get these speeds
h
you know actually so I did something
really cool for the uh the NYU people
over the weekend. So they have all these
point encoders, right? Where their obs
are basically like like a bunch of
points, right? So they have to do the
same little neural net ops and then they
do a max operation. So I wrote a custom
kernel for that and it turns out you can
make that just as fast or faster than a
standard linear layer would have been
like with a concat. Uh but it's like six
times too slow if you do it naively.
So that actually might change the way I
think about observation representation
in the future. But it also might not
like there's probably a lot more work
that I'd have to do on it and think
about it.
Each one one pixel pointed in a
direction.
Wait, four pixels of four cameras. Oh.
Oh, so that basically becomes a depth
sensor, right? Then yeah, that basically
will just become like four depth
sensors, huh? Yeah, that I believe I
believe you could navigate off depth.
That's cool.
fatigue is just terrible.
And
I don't know. I went for a really hard
run this morning as well, so
Just about tied PB for the 10K
on this course.
The goal for puffer 4 is 10 mil steps
per second like across the board pretty
much.
We're going to get puffer to 10 mil.
Mark my words.
Like that's what it's going to take for
Puffer to just be permanently the best
and then nobody be crazy enough to do
this type of thing.
4090 or a 5090. We'll see if we can hit
it on a 4090.
CPU will only matter if your M's are
slow,
though. To be fair, that might have to
be with GPUms. I don't know. That might
have to be either GPU M or a ton of CPU
M. We'll see.
I think we have to take Python out of
the loop completely. Maybe.
Got some questions about RLHF. I do not
know anything about RLHF.
Why fatigue? Just been doing a bunch of
different things this week, Jess.
Uh
worked a bunch over the weekend as well.
I went and I got some new like I got
some creatine. See if that helps. I
found a form of it that's supposed to
not destroy your stomach. So, we'll see
how that goes.
I don't know. I'm often pretty fatigued,
but um then again, I kind of have good
reason to be with all the training and
[ __ ] I do.
20 gram. If I take 20 grams and this
thing turns out not to be great on my
stomach, I'm going straight to the
hospital based on the first time I tried
just standard creatine. So, we're not
doing that [ __ ]
We will take the normal amount. Thank
you.
bad reaction to creatine.
Oh, yeah. It's like
like horrible, horrible stomach cramps
like in the restroom all night at 4 in
the morning.
didn't really try it uh again after
that. That was like a few years ago.
You really don't need creatine. I'm
actually I'm not massive now. This is
the lightest I've been in a while. I'm
just really lean.
Like I weigh um 168 right now. My
heaviest was 190.
I'm almost as strong as well. Almost as
strong
except my shoulder strength, but that's
an injury.
Honestly, I think the creatine is going
to be kind of annoying for running
because it like makes you gain a few
pounds of water weight and then you have
to carry that [ __ ]
Why does split return a freaking tuple?
Um
I should be doing a couple sets as well.
I'm just like I want to get this stupid
thing done.
Kind of used a lot of my training energy
for the day. uh this morning running.
Like anything sub nine on this course is
super high effort. It's a tough course.
And it was like 8:38 I think.
Huh?
Does it keep the freaking dimension? Is
that what I see?
I mean, I could do and do it the dumb
way.
Tiny box
pro.
That actually might be a good idea.
Where is it?
No.
Is it on Twitter? Where is this?
Let me see.
Where are the freaking specs though?
Yo, where are the specs?
though. I don't I don't think I want to
buy hardware until I do 40 and like
optimize everything so I can see actual
PF on rented machines first.
Okay, here they they list it. Um.
Oh.
Yo,
what?
So, I'm assuming that it's not actually
128 cores, right? It's got to be a 64
core chip.
128 threads or something.
We have Discord with him from when I
like bitched about the tiny box I bought
having the power cables not freaking
work.
Are they actually 256 core
machines?
Well, I mean, yeah, it was like annoying
convert cuz like was he right that I was
not debugging these as like as well as a
technician who just messes with their
hardware all day? Yes. But on the other
hand, I was debugging [ __ ] at least as
capably as his average customer, if not
better. And the [ __ ] was just whack,
right? And like they shipped two reefer
boxes, one of which just had loose power
cables and the other which just had a
straight up bad power cable. And it took
me like over two days to actually
disassemble the Swiss watch. They'd
never actually had to take out GPUs for
testing. So they didn't know what a
[ __ ] pain in the ass it was. And my
unit was also super tight. Um,
but like yeah,
I'm happy with them at the end of the
day though cuz like ultimately it was
just a couple cables and everything else
has been great since.
So are these like
Damn, this is actually 128 core chip.
Wait, but this is an $11,000 chip.
But how the [ __ ] does this work?
It's kind of silly they stick a one TB
drive in here.
That's kind of obnoxious, honestly.
That's pretty solid though.
That's pretty solid.
what they look like.
This is a dramatically better
configuration as well than they're like
um
like these boxes behind me are way they
are more of a pain in the ass. This is
like way better for maintenance as well.
hack on my 4090s. Pay my little brother
to hook it up.
I'm going to build
Yeah, I mean you probably could, but
like what do you do with it, right?
GB3. Yeah, I saw that. I don't know what
the hell that is about.
Can you get access to GB300's like
rental somewhere? At some point, I want
to benchmark probably when I get Puffer
4, I want to benchmark it on everything.
I know.
people I'm trying to hire pretty much
retired.
Yeah,
that's kind of how it would go.
And my my plan for Puffer is basically
to like keep doing this, guarantee the
future of RL, probably make a pretty
damn good amount of money in the
process. That will be enough to be both
personally comfortable and also to just
like do whatever the hell 5 to 10 person
scale science labs and various different
efforts I want forever,
you know?
kind of not try to scale um not try to
massively scale personnel, but just like
do really concentrated efforts on areas
that nobody's working at, like things
nobody's working on that are important
and then basically just ignore all the
noise of everything else.
Land in the manufacturing facility.
No.
Well, I mean, I have to still do it,
right? Like growth on Puffer has been
pretty decent for me. Basically, not
trying that hard on the business side,
like on growth at least.
We obviously try hard on our existing
contracts.
after. So after I make RL like mature
stable tech, I'm going to just go chuck
it on a bunch of different areas of um
like sim dependent research.
Well, that's pretty [ __ ] cool.
So, this runs
Oh, actually that's funny that I just
did. I'll let it run for the memes in
case it learns. But that's reusing the
same cell twice.
It actually learns. That's super funny.
Like that's using the same cell twice,
huh? It actually does better as well.
Look at that. I literally just stacked
the same layer with shared weights on
top of itself by mistake and it does
better.
That actually does a lot better.
[laughter]
That's kind of funny.
537 is the best. So, we just beat this
best sweep result so far by stacking the
network on itself twice.
Well, we're going to try it a different
way. We're going to try two separate
layers.
Right. You mean like uh my first paper
pretty much does that? My thing it's
like built off of highway nuts which do
that.
See, thanks for dropping by.
Interestingly, not as well as just
stacking on itself, though.
What is the source of income while you
work on this project? We have clients.
So this is all open source but uh
companies that have needs for custom
simulations like high perl dedicated R&D
support these are all things we offer.
but we got to go run another sweep with
this one now, I guess.
The M you work with are these policies
supposed to be like highle planners? Not
necessarily. You can do low-level
control as well.
Like here, this is this is technically a
um a lowdimensional control problem, but
a very very precise one. You can try to
play this thing and you'll just get
wrecked.
like the the opponent's really good.
Uh
some of the stuff is high level, higher
level.
This is a little bit higher level, but
not really that high level.
Yeah, it's kind of it varies a bunch.
Oh, yeah. This is like a planning type
end. I suppose it's still doing control,
but it's not like,
you know, you'd probably use this mostly
for planning stack.
Young's running stuff. We'll leave him
alone.
This is idle.
I use this for a bit.
I guess we'll just do um
Yeah, we'll just do tiny.
see how this goes.
Hey, Joseph, why are you working in a
barn?
The correct question is, why am I
working in a warehouse? And the answer
is because it's awesome.
I've got GPUs and gym equipment.
All I want.
epoxy floor. Uh the there is epoxy on
part of the floor, but then there's also
we've got 3/4 inch rubber matting on the
whole gym area.
You can kind of see.
Let's see.
There we go.
There's the whole setup pretty much.
Speaking which I think this is stable.
So I can probably
go do a couple sets.
It even has overhangs.
Those windows. Wait, what? Where can you
see my windows?
Three phase
through all the boxes.
Live in the house like a bozo. Dream of
owning a warehouse. And I should be
living in it.
Let me see.
I'm tempted to try my deadlift for the
day.
I think I should hold off though. I kind
of did something weird with my knee
earlier.
Hey, a couple light sets in while I'm
waiting for a few sweeps to
It does seem not quite as good with the
one layer version.
So, I guess we'll find out if it's like
a
layers problem or what.
So, you you'd expect to have some good
runs by now.
Um,
let's spend some time looking at the
paper to see if I've messed anything up.
How do you power?
Do you have to register as a company for
the
Well, there is a company, but no, you
don't have to register as a company.
These things draw like 10 kilowatts.
We have capacity for 50 and like farm
equipment can use way more than that.
This is not like a giant cluster. This
is pretty minimal.
the only thing that bothers me about
these is they sent me cheapo fans and
some of the fans rattle and I just don't
want to take the four hours I know it's
going to take me to like grab the boxes
with the rattly fans, like put them on a
workt, open them up, replace the fans.
Have an intern do it.
Ah,
Okay. So,
yeah, we want to check them in group
paper, right?
See, this is the problem with these
types of papers is their experiments
just suck, right?
Let's see if we can figure out anything
about this though.
Mamba have state or is it? No, Mamba is
like linear attention method, right?
very unstable. Okay. Well, this is at
least stable, but it looks to me like
the one layer
the one layer variant is worse. Oh, you
know what?
I think that I have
Let me see if I can just match the LSTM
width real quick
because I don't think I'm doing this
correctly, right?
So, shouldn't this give me
this give me the same
setup?
because the hidden dim
the hidden dim needs to be the same,
right?
You really wouldn't expect the huge
shift in hypers, would you?
Well, there's no bias.
Interesting.
99 items.
Okay. Okay. 842. So, we're starting to
get to like maybe this can actually
solve, right?
Uh, this one's having a hard time of
life.
This is getting to like maybe we can
solve the task.
Uh, the orthogonalized in it actually
helped a lot. That looks like
it could just be like jank.
Now, let me see if we can figure out why
the param counts are so different,
right?
Uh, of course it'll be puffer
constellation on everything,
but there's a little more to do before
then
in features.
Okay. So I think it has two blocks of
this, right? So it's 512 x 128 but the
LSTM has two such blocks.
anything you set up on 1B besides
defaults? Yeah, I typically will set up
points like um I'll set up plots like
this where I have parameter and then I
have um score so I can get like stable
ranges and stuff. I also do like sweep
progress so I can see over time am I
getting better and better runs or not.
And I do quite a bit of stuff.
Good time to mention to folks if you're
new around here, you can support my work
for absolutely free just by starting the
repository. It actually helps way more
than you'd ever expect right here. And
uh we are currently at
4090 stars.
4090 stars. That is awesome.
That is really cool.
Just chugging on through here.
I actually really like the graphics in
this thing here.
Is this like billboard sprites? Yeah, it
is. Right.
I think it's just the texture on it.
This is just really well done.
No, we don't. We don't have any RTS
stuff. The action spaces are pretty
tricky. You'd have to think about them.
Uh,
right. So, I was trying to match the
dimensions of the LSTM as best as I
could. Let me go take a little bit more
of a look at our mining grew.
So for this case, this is the easiest
one, right? So it's just you do
Where are the default config values of
pop restored? I can't seem to find them
in the repo. They're there.
There you go. Puffer lib config.
There's a default file in here. And then
there's there are overrides for all the
different M's.
Now you mentioned there there are styles
of code that were good but you could ne
personally never work with. What do you
look for in terms of people how just how
people structure their code? Uh, minimal
abstraction. Write the thing top to
bottom in the damn simplest way
possible.
That's pretty much it.
No like OOP dogmas. No like I must
modularize and future proof the crap out
of everything.
No, every single like file must have a
billion lines of test coverage. Couple
tests are fine.
Just like people who really value
simplicity,
speed and simplicity.
If you look at neural MMO, it's one of
the most complex RL environments out
there and like a freshman undergrad can
read it like just top to bottom.
There's like a couple things I think
with the terrain shader and like a
couple of the rendering tricks that are
complicated, but everything else is just
dead simple.
It runs million and a half steps per
second per core.
right. What is this? G. So two gate and
hidden.
actually. What the hell is this?
Wait, so
G.
What the hell is Oh, this is G.
Okay,
this just an activation.
So
you do this
So would it be expansion factor four
then?
I think it's four, right?
uh because it has a projection in it,
right?
Okay. So, this might not be what we want
either,
but it's worth running it just to see
Yeah, this is not the same thing though,
right? Because
Yeah, this expansion factor is not the
same thing.
like the LSTM really has four separate
gates.
trying to think what's the best set of
experiments to look at. Does anybody
have anything else with mining?
These are just from the paper.
No original work.
The heck is this?
Abandoned little library
ascend high processors. I called I used
to use that name. Dang it.
I think Kyouong posted full sweeps of
this exact environment right at breakout
before.
We should definitely be able to get some
solves
if this is not just a bad architecture.
It's like pretty close.
I guess we can keep it going. It could
just be different hypers.
It's possible.
And then this one just takes a while, I
suppose.
Let's understand this one first.
So ht is output time tanh.
Output is a linear projection of these
Does it make sense that this thing even
works? Like
Oh, okay.
I think if we
we should be able to get something with
this.
I mean,
I like there are two distinct
possibilities in my mind here, right?
So, one is that like fundamentally
there's a weaker recurrence relationship
and you just can't get anything as good
out of this. Um,
the other would be that
you need to just stack it like you need
two layers at least because
the uh
the nonlinearities are weaker.
This was rejected.
The [ __ ]
gated recurrent.
We noted originates from Yes.
I want to see if this has comparisons to
the original
this. Yeah, this is very low quality
work.
Uh the experiments at least are very low
quality work.
Token mixer.
Uh, yeah, this is useless.
Yeah, this is useless. It's got embedded
layer norm and all sorts of [ __ ]
I guess this module though
HRU we could use this.
Let me see if they have any experiments
are useful.
Dude, I don't know what the [ __ ] is
wrong with people. like it doesn't.
Nobody has the baseline that you'd
obviously want.
Okay, let me see if I can find Let me
just look at this real quick.
So this is
The forget gate and the output
activation are the most critical
components.
I remember this paper.
Let's see.
Well, this is an [ __ ] comment.
It's like a completely different paper
as well.
like the most douchebag comment I've
ever seen on a paper. Holy [ __ ]
I got a wait. I got very few but a
handful of timeouts.
I set max moves insanely high. Huh.
Weird.
This has like layer norm and linear [ __ ]
in it. Like [ __ ]
You need the forget gate. Cool. Oh, this
is not tuned though.
Keep reading this.
Uh, Jess, I'm like I'm reading through
basically Mingru and all the related
stuff and I've never seen this before.
So, the author of another similar paper
who's not a reviewer on this paper, just
like being a total douche on the open
review.
Like, it's kind of sad. I think that
this contributed to this paper getting
rejected and this is like a dramatically
better written paper than this imbecile.
Like, okay, they they were able to run
bigger experiments and they have a
fancier model, but like this paper is
actually way way way better at
presenting these Yes.
It's like annoying as well cuz yeah,
this other paper has um has better
experiments, but yeah, congratulations,
you had more compute and it's it's like
a much more complex architecture and it
doesn't do anywhere near as good idea of
like presenting the main point
and they all have the same issue, right?
Where like they don't actually compare
to the original LSTM or GRU as far as
I've seen, which is like the one obvious
[ __ ] experiment you would want. They
don't have, but like none of them have
it.
They actually went and they did the
experiments as well.
yeah, that's good.
Cool.
Okay. So, this is this is true.
Um,
This is why you don't work in academia.
It's like such a [ __ ] show.
Okay. Well, let's go take a look at our
current sweep and then we'll go look at
the other stuff.
Uh, so we are starting to get some
decent runs. This is a full solve right
here.
And We'll
solve in 95 mil as well.
Oh, uh, yeah, that should be fine.
And this one
much much slower. So, this is going to
be a while.
Okay, let's go take a look at this.
complex valued recurrence
for get gates with monotonically
increased lower bound values.
They don't have small results
or RL.
Yeah. So these this one is actually kind
of useless I think to me.
Um
adding complex values
What about this one?
Maybe this one gets saved by appendices.
Let me see if there's anything usable.
Do they even have code for this thing?
They do have code for this thing. Okay,
that redeems this a little bit.
Let's see how this looks in comparison.
You got to be [ __ ] me. They put a
like they put this script that doesn't
actually have the freaking
bruh.
You put this here and then you're
criticizing the other paper that's
actually good. [ __ ] off.
This has sigmoid sigmoid tanh, but
that's for LSTM. Where's GRU?
Linear sigmoid and some dots. Okay, so
this really doesn't have um many
activations on it.
The LSTM might be a little better
though.
D tan H of linear of X
I is this
and this
drop range restriction. So instead of
doing tanh
goes to linear
two
just two gates.
They don't have any tanh.
And this one is sigmoid. Sigid sillu
very similar right
and they put layer norm on the output in
linear
I don't think changes it at all All
right.
But I'm a little sketched with their
LSTM formulation because the GRU one
seems to be
I don't know if this is a good
adaptation, right?
If they do worse with um LSTM,
LSTM should be better.
training runtime. Let me see what other
charts they have in here.
If I can get this to work, this will be
very nice. Like this is a dramatically
better paper as well.
Right now it's I just wish all of these
like none of them bother to compare to
the original model which is so
obnoxious,
right? Like it's the most obvious thing
you'd want. Like why why are you
comparing this [ __ ] to transformers and
stuff? Like if you just make a better
recurrent cell like you realize we still
use recurrent cells for stuff, right?
So this says
looks like they needed two layers to
make this thing work.
We'll probably grab this setup from
them.
bit space.
They had to do this [ __ ] on Pund's gh
and T4s. That's brutal.
embedding dimension of 128.
Three layers.
Yeah, but this is like such a different
setup, right?
Okay. I mean this is like we are getting
stuff to solve. I guess
we get the parto.
Yeah. 50 seconds.
And I haven't optimized this thing yet
either really
And presumably, yeah, this has to be
able to train way faster. That's another
thing to look at, the actual speed
diffs.
Um
This take super long.
No, it doesn't look like it takes super
long.
This paper has
e- mamba
This is 2024.
Would
you say OS and networking is relevant
for the work you do? No, not really.
Basic systems dev is though. Basic
systems dev is very important.
This looks way harder to make fast,
right?
Okay, I mean these linear variants then
are pretty much what we have.
a little sketchy.
You know what
[sighs]
can we do?
Let me play with a couple little things,
right? Let's play with a couple things.
cuz like I kind of suspect that this
thing is just lacking nonlinearities.
Right. Like the LSTM actually has a
pretty nice set of nonlinearities. Makes
it pretty representative.
What's the pros with using Docker during
dev? You get the same uh you get the
same dev environment every time. And if
you break something, it's instantaneous
to spin up a new environment.
Pretty much the only annoying bit of it
is like GPU disconnecting and other
small Docker like Docker bugs,
Okay, we'll see. Is this significant?
This is 600 score, right?
Just with the defaults.
44 seconds. This was 600 score.
Do you know of any hierarchical policies
I should read up on? No, we don't really
have any of that at the moment. The only
thing that's kind of worth looking at is
like the fast slow RNN stuff maybe.
Okay. So, actually it looks like adding
just giving it one extra layer here
helps quite a bit, right?
How do they work? They don't really work
for the most part.
There's your answer.
Whoops.
Answer that.
That's a shame at a shower thought.
Um,
the search is different.
Search trees is different from
hierarchical
finish the biggest advantage.
I think I'm about the same amount of
productive Ronaldo because I don't
distract myself like I do normally, but
then I spend time answering chat and
then we get all sorts of people
interested in the project. It helps with
all the promotion. It helps getting
contributions.
It's just generally a good thing.
Prevents me from losing the ability to
speak in complete sentences from just
grinding research solo for months on end
as well.
That's a real thing that can happen as
it turns out.
Not bad.
And we're getting solves, right?
It does seem a bit less powerful,
though.
Oh,
lol. Um, okay. So, this is more params,
but this solves.
Does this solve consistently?
I just use the same defaults and this
solves.
Young. Hey, Kyouong. So, this is this is
cool. I'm using your new sweeps code. Uh
do you have
do you have like a sweep on breakout? I
want to see the first like 200
experiments because what I'm doing right
now is I'm looking at mining GRU. So,
I'm trying to get us a faster recurrent
cell basically. And um
I'm running some experiments for that
and it's a little tricky and it seems to
me like the base architecture is a
little weaker than a standard LSTM, but
I want to confirm.
Yeah, I kind of need like like sweet
progress over numbum experiments type
thing, you know?
There's a lot of runto-run variants on
these
tension is quadratic. Yeah.
Yeah, it is.
I need to remember to give myself a
reminder for my meeting.
It would seem to me that the correct
thing to do would be to do um
on layers two like this
you just to be like just to be certain
you can't just do this right
I don't think this works but
Well, with tag break six
Nobody can write code anymore that is
not slow.
Lag. Lag. Lag. Lag. Lag. You're not even
doing any operations. Come on.
How do I set this thing like
grouping merges everything? Oh,
Do you have like the sweep over time or
whatever it is? like how these
I just like mess with this.
So wait up time
the created time stamp.
What is up with the uh this like weird
axis [ __ ]
Like,
write software that doesn't suck,
please.
Yeah, but Kyouong I like breakout is the
really fast
quick check. I have the most amount of
like I have the most general experiments
on that.
Okay. Well, this is super obnoxious that
I can't check. I'm pretty sure this
thing is worse, though. So, we've got
this one. Then we've got, was it this
one?
And so we get 50 second solve I think is
our best
I guess I can just go back to um
hang on
it created time step
what was it before that it was like
runtime
Yeah, I have uptime. Okay, so this
should be pretty close.
You're on 409. So, you should be even a
little better off.
I mean, I should be better off, but then
yeah, the thing that bothers me is like
you just have so many runs here.
You just have so many runs here that are
solving
Yeah, it's probably like a quarter of
the runs or whatever.
And then if I look at mine,
I mean, I kind of got the information I
needed from that, which is that Yeah,
yours is still a little better.
I mean, this is decently fast to be
fair.
Oh, wait. We didn't get the uh the
profile fix.
Yeah, I don't know why this is in here,
but
for whatever reason, these two lines
commented screws up our profile.
default plus LSTM.
Oh, this actually has a bunch of time on
learning still.
Didn't this be super fast or does it
need a colonel?
I mean it's just a bunch of ops, right,
that aren't getting fused most likely.
It probably plays well with compile,
you'd imagine, right?
Yeah, we can just update and install.
Okay, we do get something out of compile
here and learn is down to 20% time.
So yeah, realistically
realistically we can get this to be much
faster. I think
that's 3 mil.
All right, we're going to keep trying
some stuff then. This is uh quite good
progress.
So I think we're going to try to get
pietorches muon.
the pie torches. Mu on a few other
things. Let me get a couple sets in. Let
me use a restroom. I'll be back in a
few. And um
yeah, this is definitely worth at least
investigating like more deeply.
Yeah, we can definitely like one like
sidebyside these. All right, I'll be
right back.
right. Well, let's see what we got from
our sweeps. Right. This one is finished
fully.
Okay. We get some some reasonable thing
out of this.
Okay. So, we can run
back over there.
And this one is super slow.
Doesn't seem to be amazing.
50 runs.
Yeah. So, this does not seem to be
amazing.
like too narrow, I guess.
Okay. Well, while this is running, let's
do something.
Does seem effective
immediately.
Okay.
And now the main thing.
I mean, it's kind of cringe, but yeah,
I'm good at what I do.
It mostly feels like I do relatively
simple things that are somehow just
absent everywhere. though. Every so
often I do something that's genuinely
pretty hard.
I love your indie devs. Pretty awesome.
They just do cool Enough.
Just go ask
where is
Hey, Kvert.
Yep.
Parsing through equations.
Yeah, I always just find it easier to
convert it to a loop, man. Like
recursion is just a stack. You can do
the stack yourself and then not debug
[ __ ] horribly.
That's so much easier.
I mean, if this doesn't work, I'll just
do it myself. But I just don't like
API obnoxious.
Dude, what the [ __ ] All right, we're
closing Grock. Stupid thing.
Thought I'd done this already, but
apparently not.
Well, I mean, the other one they serve
is freaking llama 70 bill.
can't optimize
long leaf tensor
Okay. So, don't inherit and then just do
do the steps manually.
We can do that. That's easier.
This is so obnoxious. How do they not
have this somewhere?
Oh, is this is just disgustingly bad,
right?
form's way worse though because we don't
have the uh the other optimizer.
Not super easy, right?
Annoyingly enough.
And great, it doesn't work as well as
heavy Oh,
your weight decay.
Um,
epsilon
Okay,
that's that's a lot better, right?
And we'll also we will see on the latest
the speed with um with Lucas's
implementation.
Maybe slight edge to torch. It's hard to
say. A hell of a lot less annoying. I
can say that.
H.
Okay. Interesting.
So, our new one is just as good then, if
not better.
New one is just as good if not better.
Okay. So let's just um
I mean we can merge in a few things by
now, right?
Not amazing.
Okay.
Well, let's just merge this.
We'll do Muan into um the Mr.
Is there a place where you can see
research failed?
Terrible. They publish.
So if you have an idea but someone tried
it and it's terrible they publish it.
Um
so negative results generally are good.
The problem with negative results is you
have to demonstrate a very high bar of
execution so that you can be uh you can
be fairly certain right that it's that
there is some fundamental reason it
doesn't work and it's not just that you
implemented it wrong.
Okay. So, I'm fairly convinced that we
should not be requiring
256 hidden dimension for breakout,
right? Unless, let me make sure.
I believe the puffer lip baseline
So it's 128 here
8.
So this is the this is the config.
And this is slower.
It's annoying.
But then this isn't really fair, right?
The the real test would be like,
okay, so now this is like uh this is
much more reasonable, but this model is
tiny.
I don't like the idea that you have to
go up to 256
hidden dimension just because of this.
What do you mean? HRL using quad trees.
No, hierarchical RL is like the
architecture itself is hierarchical,
right?
Quat tree CNN's. What? What do you mean
quatry? Like CNN's do that by default.
That's how they work.
like it's by
combining like um filters over larger
and larger receptive regions.
It's not exactly quattry but like the
idea is similar enough.
Okay. Okay. I mean this is very close to
parameter match though is the Okay.
Okay,
this is interesting.
M
10 24 M's
back
gives me a much more reasonable value
for lambda.
about the same.
If flipped co
I don't like this 0.1.
Um, why is this not learning massively
faster? I guess.
Even faster, of course.
Okay, so that's a nice speed up. So I
mean that's like the overhead of doing
this in Python. That's fine.
Okay, so now we actually have this at
comparable speed to before.
I'd like to know why
it isn't faster.
Try them in LSTM. I suppose
that might be nice.
figure out this bug
real quick.
I'm gonna have to get dinner pretty soon
because I got a 700 p.m. later for
client.
Favorite food? I don't know, man. I like
plenty of food. Meat.
Multi-agent soccer right now. Really?
We have a a similar project planned very
very soon, man.
Lots of selfplay work going on right
now.
Oh, that's you. Yeah. Um
there's a little bit of a learning
curve, but it gets easier and faster
every version with lots of good
educational material as well if you're
new.
making it harder than it needs to be.
That's usually how it goes.
About 20% of your time reading
resources, 80% building is about right.
And 25 if you're really new.
The RL guide that I posted should be
very helpful for that though.
It really does try to take you through a
lot in not much time.
Okay, so now we're getting like
somewhere sort of, I think. Um, let's
just
Love the outfit for it.
The outfit.
What outfit?
The guide is um
the guide is just this thing.
Oh, the iceberg. Yeah, that one's also
that's a fun watch. That gives you a
highle overview. Uh the real content for
learning uh and like following along is
the
the opinionated guide though.
I'm happy if you watch the uh the
iceberg video as well. I put a lot of
time into it. Not many people watched
it.
Okay. So, I mean, we do have like
several
several of these now.
more expensive ones.
They'll get way faster though.
I'm not a huge fan of that though. I'm
really not a huge fan of that.
Stupid UI, man.
I can't wait to just stop using this
garbage.
Okay. So, yeah, they all have um
so obnoxious, man.
You should be able to get something out
of this, I would think.
Oops.
Update torch.
I guess we should consider it pretty
good that it's the same speed
as uh Nvidia's optimized kernel without
having like anything done for it so far.
So we will run this. This will be way
faster.
And uh we can see from this
what we think of mining groom. Try
minstm next.
That doesn't work.
A few different variants we can try.
I mean, that's cool, but why the hell
would you ever do type? That's horrible.
Like, why would you ever do it that way?
Okay. So, we will figure this one out. I
want to just look at a couple last
things so we have a plan.
Well, we can always do the uh the per
comparisons to this thing, right?
Yeah, I don't think anybody's done
proper ablations.
I mean, I guess I would suspect that you
need to stack it a little. No.
Like, how would you not need to stack it
a little bit
is it nonlinear even in the previous
state?
That's so weird
and I guess it is nonlinear in the
previous state isn't
I think we got to mess around with a
couple different versions of this.
Do linear. You do linear. And you do
this.
Interesting.
I mean, there are like multiple of these
I can try.
Yeah, there multiple of these I can just
try.
I mean they are testing these versus
stronger baselines in a sense, but
Worse. I'm seeing worse PF.
Decent, but worse PF. Hey, Matt.
Okay, here it is with clipping.
And we'll see if this does anything, I
suppose, while I get dinner.
Okay.
Well, I'm going to go get some food. Um,
I might do uh a late night stream. It
depends how long my meeting after dinner
goes. I might just do like an extra
hour. We'll see to like look at these
results. Um I really do hope this works
because I think we can make this much
faster,
but we can't really give up um we can't
really give up the power of the LSTM
cell and we want a stronger model, not a
weaker model. So, we'll see how that
goes.
In any event, thank you folks. Um
if you're interested in my work
generally, it's all in puffer.ai. Start
the GitHub. It's free. It helps me out.
You can get involved on the Discord.